des parcs à sapin disposés un peu
partout dans saint cyr l'école au total
1400 ont été récoltés ces 900 sapin de
plus par rapport à l'année dernière une
évolution due à l'augmentation des
points de collecte mais aussi grâce à la
prise de conscience des habitants j'ai
fait ça dans une démarche écologique et
le parc à sapin à côté de chez moi donc
j'ai décidé de venir le déposer dans
park à sa fin c'est très bon pour
l'environnement puisque ce qui est issu
de la nature retournent à la nature et
que comme ça on respecte vraiment le
cycle vertueux de la nature et on est
parfaitement respectueux de
l'environnement mais attention les
sapins avec encore des décorations ou
floqué ne sont pas accepter ces derniers
contiennent des produits toxiques et ne
peuvent pas être recyclés d'après les
premières estimations de l'agglomération
versailles grand parc 7000 sa pince ont
été récoltés puis broyés dans une
démarche écologique donc ce broyat il
peut être utilisé soit en paillage et
peut être un petit peu acide donc on
peut potentiellement le mélanger avec
deux types de broyage d'autres 1 pour
mettre au pied des plantes ou bien il
sert très bien pour tout ce qui est pour
la délimitation des allées ou pour en
fait en tant que désherbant naturel
parce que comme il est acide il permet
voilà d'avoir ses usages et ensuite
pendant l'été le broyat maintient
l'humidité eau chaude et cela vous évite
d arrosage cela vous fait faire des
économies d'eau les saint cyriens pour
mon venir chercher leurs broyat à partir
du mercredi 26 janvier entre 10h et 12h
ou de 14h à 16h au parc maurice meluc